demon slayer season 2 has just been
announced to be adapted sometime
in 2021 which is huge news among the
anime community
with the unprecedented success of the
movie moog and train
becoming the highest grossing film in
the history of japanese cinema
as well as the popular series before it
of course there's
a lot riding on the next season to come
and i'm personally very excited
i think that demon slayer only gets
better after the first season you know
as someone who read the manga
and today i'm going to give a brief
spoiler-free of course
rundown of what we should expect from
the second season
both content-wise with the general plot
and characters at play
and logistically with animation season
length etc
i'm first going to tackle animation and
the studio and then move on to the
content and arc that the season will
focus on and then the length of the
season so make sure to stick around to
the end of the video to get the full
rundown of demon slayer season 2 and
what we should expect
so first looking at animation wise and
whether the season will fail here or not
is definitely not something to worry
about
the second season will continue to be
animated by ufotable according to my
anime list
and seeing as how they also animated
moog train
there is just no way ufotable would drop
such a hot series
and putting it in the most simplest
terms possible
ufotable doesn't miss any project they
animate essentially never fails in the
arts and visuals department i mean they
have such a beautiful balance
of hand-drawn animation and cgi that is
truly unrivaled by just about any other
studio in the industry
and a large part of that is not only
because of the huge budget that they
allocate to each project
but because they also don't overburden
themselves with multiple series at a
time
this is something that mapa is suffering
from right now with attack on titan and
jujutsu kaisen on their plate
arguably the two biggest series
currently airing
but ufotable tends to only take one
maybe two works at a time
the studio itself started off really
strong in the late 2000s with the karano
kyokai series which was already visually
astounding for the time and continued to
improve in the early 2010s and make a
name for the studio with the fate series
their animation of fate stay night
unlimited blade works around 2014
earned the show a notorious nickname of
unlimited budget
works just because of how insane and
almost
od the animation was ufotable did such a
great job that in my opinion
as someone who really enjoys a well
animated show was
leagues beyond the majority of other
studios
and of course right after the fate
series and the movies that followed it
they moved on to demon slayer and
there's no doubt in my mind that
ufotable will continue to improve on
their animation and upgrade season 2
visuals wise
i mean look i'm just going to play a
couple clips from previous ufotable
movies and shows and this will just show
you how the studio
really never fails to amaze me
uh
[Music]
i mean just look at these scenes man if
you haven't watched the fate series
please do watch it
and this is really important to because
a massive part of demon slayer's growth
has to be attributed to the animation
the series has blown up on levels we
really haven't seen since the popularity
of attack on titan and like tokyo ghoul
around 2013 and 2014
and you have to acknowledge how the
animation has contributed to that
not to say that the series wouldn't do
well without ufotable backing it because
it's great and i've read it and it's
still
incredible standalone but i doubt it
would have reached the meteoric levels
it's at now within the anime community
without ufotable backing it
now onto the actual content and what
will happen in this season
again i want to reiterate that while i
won't be mentioning spoilers or anything
like that
i will bring up the general plot and
characters who are integral to this arc
so we'll see the animation of the
entertainment district arc which follows
our three boys
tanjiro inosuke and zenitsu as they join
the sound pillar tengen uzui on a
mission to yoshiwara
for those of you unfamiliar with general
japanese history
yoshiwara was the red light district and
so
expectedly this arc does have a more
mature setting
and one that is more connected to the
world of demon slayer itself
with both season 1 and the movie we
don't really see how the demon slayers
interact with normal people and
civilians much
which is something we will definitely
see more of during this arc as it takes
place
in a living bustling town and their
mission is to investigate rumors of
demons in the district
so it has more of an investigative
mystery feeling to it it's certainly
a fresh take on demon slayer and it's an
arc that's bringing a lot of new things
we haven't seen from the series yet
anime-wise
it's personally one of my favorite arcs
the new pillar we meet
is really cool his powers are awesome
and it also shows huge character growth
for everyone but especially tanjiro and
nezuko
i feel like i shouldn't even have to
bring this up but of course it has some
great fights as well
i think that it'll go way beyond how
good the first season was
and so the entertainment district arc is
pretty long it's 30 chapters
to scale that for anyone who hasn't read
the manga or isn't familiar with
generally how
manga is adapted into anime lengthwise
the first season covered around 50
chapters in total
and so while i can see possibly the
second season being a full
24 to 26 episode season i really really
doubt this will happen
i mean first the teaser image we've been
given of the season
is solely the sound pillar tengen so
it's clear that the main focus is
already on the entertainment district
arc
and 2 the ark that follows this one is
also huge
so it'll be really hard to fit it into a
24 to 26 episode season without making
it feel really rushed
and so season 2 will likely be only
around 12 to 13 episodes
this is very typical with a big series
after the first season to start
only airing in single core seasons i
mean as the show gets very popular
keeping up on a weekly schedule becomes
very burdensome for the studio and
shortening the length is better not only
for their health but for their
productivity and producing content that
really looks good
and is appealing to viewers and another
reason that shows often do this is so
that the studio can prolong
how long the anime airs simply to get
more money and garner more popularity
we see it in just about every big series
really attack on titan after season 1
did this and split every season after
into 12 to 13 episodes haikyuu did this
after season 2 as well
it usually just doesn't logistically
make sense to make longer seasons with
such a popular show
so yeah it'll probably be only 12 to 13
episodes which might be disappointing to
you
but it will surely be really good and
cover an amazing arc
so look forward to it and so that was
just my brief rundown of demon slayers
season 2 and what you should expect from
it going in with
almost no knowledge yet if you enjoyed
this video make sure to like and comment
on whether i should make more videos on
demon slayer in the future
like and all you need to know before
season 2 type thing
i'd love to keep talking about it on the
channel the manga is great and the
series i know is going to go far
as always this has been the anime
culture corner i hope you enjoyed the
video
don't forget to like and subscribe for
future in-depth show manga and character
analyses
you